and and given that divergence how do you
now regard what is now the completed
sort of corpus of Game of Thrones the
HBO series within this broad world of
Westeros which you know you've explored
in different directions
I mean how where does it fit in well
it's it's it's two different ways of
telling the story I mean I ask people
sometimes how many children Scarlett
O'Hara have and for those of you who
know gone with the wind anybody you know
best-selling most popular movie of all
time and a mega bestseller of course in
Margret Mitchell's book Scarlett O'Hara
has three children in the movie Scarlett
O'Hara has one child which is correct
which is right which is true true
scholar however had no children because
she didn't exist she was a made-up
fictional character so both of them are
are equally true you could do it Gone
with the Wind graphic novel next one she
could have twelve children that would
also be equally true you know where
we're making up stories here so yeah I'm
telling a version then in my books and
the show which had different constraints
and different deadlines and different
needs has told a very similar story
close in some respects exactly the same
as some respects different other
respects can I ask how the process of
sharing a world with other writers on
the page that you've described wildcards
compares to sharing a world the world of
Westeros with other creators in Game of
Thrones you know you might have heard of
it the biggest TV show in the world you
know what is what is easy what is
difficult when you suddenly have to open
this world out to other writers other
creators other minds well there are
challenges to it certainly
you know when I first got involved in
television in the in the mid 80s
Twilight Zone was the first show I was
hired to write for and then Beauty and
the Beast and then I had five years of
development where I was making of my own
shows but remember I sold my first short
story in 71 so from 71 to 85 I was
active in the world of prose and short
stories books and that's a very lonely
existence it's you know you sitting in
front of a computer screen but the
cursor blinking and trying to think of
something to fill that screen and before
computers it's you sitting in front of a
typewriter which I did start on back in
the beginning and facing a blank sheet
of paper when I first got to Hollywood I
actually loved the idea of you know I'm
working with all these other people and
you know you're in a room you're on a
show staff and you're writing things and
then then like the next day later you're
in the writers room and the other
writers are critiquing what you wrote
they're making suggestions you go back
and you rewrite it you rewrite it maybe
a couple times
other people way in and then eventually
gets greenlit to film and you're
suddenly working with the with a
director you're casting actors you're
sitting in casting sections and actors
some of whom you've actually heard of or
coming in and reading your lines and you
know it's it's it's a high the first
story of mine ever produced was Roger
Zelazny zhh and that my adaptation of
Roger Leslie's last defender of Camelot
the climax of which takes place in
Stonehenge in another dimension and
suddenly because of what Roger wrote and
what I wrote in the script here's all
these people building Stonehenge on a
set behind my behind my office that's
real high and you know this is the
social aspect visiting the set meeting
the actors working with other writers
who are or you know very bright and
talented going to dailies I mean coming
into the office every day and your
assistant brings you a cup of coffee and
you know you have a script meeting at
one point you have a casting session you
watch the dailies from the previous
day's shooting it's it's a whole
different world than the lonely writer
you're sitting in wrong in it is is it
distracting
no I I loved much of it but here's the
other side of it the other side of the
same coin is there's all these [ __ ]
other people who are telling you what to
do
they all have [ __ ] opinions you know
they don't like that line or day they
they say my character wouldn't say that
if they're an actor or the director
wants the scene redone or the network
won't let you do something that's studio
say they don't have the money for it you
know the other writers have different
ideas so so it the same thing is both
very good and very very bad very
frustrating that you know there's no as
a creative person there's no control
greater than what you get when you are
sitting all alone in front of a computer
in front of a typewriter you're making
up your world you can do anything you
want your god in television you're sort
of a god but sort of a minor God there
are bigger gods above you they can smack
you down at any time so two different
ways of of telling stories and both of
them have their pluses and minuses so
you used to write an episode per season
at the beginning you write an episode
per season of Thrones or was it was that
yes the contractual stick that was a
country I had the option to write an
episode the other season because I knew
you know I mean going back again to my
10 years in television you know I I
worked on Twilight Zone did a little bit
of work on Max Headroom but my episodes
were never filmed then I worked for
three years the entire run of Beauty and
the Beast at that point I'd risen
through the ranks in the television
hierarchy from from staff writer which
was my first position you know that
staff writer is a very lowly position
but it's the only one that has two word
writer in the title
and then from there I moved up the story
editor an executive story editor and
co-producer producer supervising
producer and I was set to become an
executive producer a showrunner which is
the you know the big title but then
beauty to be extended and then I got a
development deal with it just paying me
Studios are paying me money to come up
with ideas for TV shows to come up with
ideas for TV movies feature films
what-have-you and I wrote a number of
those over the ensuing five years and
that could be very lucrative but
ultimately I found it very unsatisfying
because nothing was made you know they
they pay you and you have meetings
meetings you get invested in the world
you love these characters and then they
don't they don't make them nobody nobody
ever reads what you wrote except for
guys in a room and I guess I discovered
something about myself that I'm a little
like an actor or something I want the
applause or I want them to throw the
rotten fruit of me but whatever I want
to come out on the stage at the end of
I'm done and know that an audience
whether it's the audience in a theater
of a few hundred or whether it's an
order audience of 20 million on the
television sets of America has seen what
I've come up with I wanted that but at
that stage when I finally went back to
two books with Game of Thrones I I
really wanted to be a showrunner I
wanted to do it and be the captain of
the ship instead of just a the first
mate or one of the swabbies but then 20
years passed and by the time Game of
Thrones was ready to go to HBO number
one I was right in the middle of a
series I would I had four books out and
I was struggling to finish dance with
dragons at that time and I knew there
were two more after that I couldn't you
know being a showrunner on a television
show is a 24 hour a day job I'm it's a
hugely high-stress busy job this crises
every day there's always something to do
it takes all your attention I couldn't
do that without abandoning the books
entirely and that I wasn't willing to do
books were still number one
but I did want to keep my hand in so I
got a contract that said I could write
one episode per season and I did in the
beginning seasons but it took me about a
month to do each of those episodes even
though they were adaptations almost in
every case adaptations of scenes and
material that I'd already written in the
book so I was just really transferring
it from one medium to another at a
certain point when we got into season
five the butterfly effect had kicked in
and the show had gotten a little further
away from my books and I no longer had
adapt ations to do I would have had to
be working on scenes that never occurred
in the books and so forth and at that
point I said well it was taking me a
month just to do the straight
adaptations if it here it's going to
take me six weeks minimum maybe two
months to write these scripts it's it's
too long and David and Anna have done a
great job I think I'll step back and
just concentrate on the books and that's
what I did